there is always a demolition before
there's a renovation when you stop
looking at the circumstance and look at
what you can do with who you are in that
circumstance then everything changes
emotions do not have intellect that's
what it is it's understanding the
concept that emotions cannot think so as
real as they feel they have to be
bounced off the truth or they will have
you all over the place emotions cannot
be the engine they have to be the
caboose
everything that happens in my life will
work together for good
and there he is what's going on how are
you good how are you man good good good
just just taking a seat and excited to
talk to you for a bit i love it i love
it ladies and gentlemen i want to
introduce you to a creative force
an an entrepreneur
and an author of a new book called
divine disruption for youtube we're
going to link that in the description
below to go check it out a new friend of
the channel mr anthony evans welcome
aboard man thank you very much man it's
good good to be with you i appreciate
your time
so there's so many ways i was diving in
your story there's so many ways to take
this conversation but i thought starting
with entrepreneurship is a good good
place because most of my audience are
entrepreneurs got it yeah and in looking
at your story in the music production
company that you started and just
when you started your your journey
feeling like you didn't belong you
didn't quite fit in and trying to find
your place and then you decide i'm just
going to bet on myself i'm going to
launch my own production company i'm
going to be my own manager i'm going to
be my own booking agent
i'm going to do it all myself because i
don't quite fit into the mold that
everybody wants to put me in
a lot of people when that when they're
at that phase they quit they give up
they say like why can't why can't it
just work out and instead of taking on
those roles i just stopped so what what
was the thing that made you say i'm
gonna figure out a way to do everything
to start making progress on my dream
well it wasn't necessarily easy because
i
i appreciate i appreciate the hype i
mean that's amazing but it wasn't
necessarily easy at the beginning to be
told no and you don't fit in all those
things now for those of you don't know
i'm a musician i'm in gospel music but
earlier on there's such a there's like a
real divided line in in contemporary
gospel music especially earlier on so
not fitting
was was not a good feeling to have the
industry go this just doesn't work but i
knew that there was
a for lack of a better i'll say this
because i'm not here with entrepreneurs
there was a market for what i do
but commercially it didn't work like did
you know what i'm saying so i knew that
there was a mar i knew there was a
market for what i did people were asking
me to come sing even though the radio
wasn't playing my music so i i just
decided i can't allow an industry and
radio um guys who aren't playing my
music to determine whether i'm gonna
actually go do what i know that i've
been gifted at and i know that i'm
called to and all that stuff so
i also
have
parents that are very much
been told no most of their adult lives
because of what they're doing and they
figured out ways around it so i watched
that and didn't realize i was
taking on so much of them that i mean
i'm their dna obviously but taking on so
much of the mindset that they had which
is
create your own path nobody can tell you
that you can't do something especially
when you know that you're good at it you
know your call to it
an
industry doesn't get to decide whether
you get to do it sometimes it gets to
decide the capacity in which you do it
and then the brevity in which you start
to do it but
overall it can't decide so i just
started making the calls and going to
places and learning how to do
whatever it was like the the booking or
the the lighting and the things that you
mentioned the buses i had to figure that
all out on my own
and i had no idea that i was that a
production company was being birthed
back then i was just doing i was just
rejected and it's so hard but i didn't
know that if i wouldn't have been
rejected back then i wouldn't have the
company that i have now
and so where do you get the strength
from
to go and disrupt the industry to say
hey this industry wasn't made for me
yet and what i want to do so i'm going
to make my own path because people love
that idea especially entrepreneurs we
love that concept i don't want to listen
to the man or i don't want to have a
boss i want to do it right but then you
start like it's hard to clear a path you
gotta chop down trees and push things
out like it's really
difficult and you don't see results at
the beginning so where do you get the
strength from or where did you get the
strength from to say i don't care i'm
gonna go off and do it well a couple
things one my faith is always going to
play a role in in me finding strength to
keep moving and keep pressing on so my
i'm a man of faith i believe i don't
push my faith on people but it has been
such a vital part of who i am as a human
being that i just tell my story and
that's always going to be a part of it
so knowing that there is a purpose and a
plan that's bigger than me that god has
set before me is huge but also
in addition to that well because of that
redefining what success was to me made
me push forward because i became a
pursuer of internal peace and part of my
internal peace was am i doing what i
know i'm called to do am i doing it
excellently even if nobody's watching
like how excellent can i get this how
i became a pursuer of that
and then that leads you to quote-unquote
what we consider to be success sometimes
which is people's eyes on you which is
not necessarily
the the wrong infrastructure and a bunch
of people's eyes on you can feel like
failure i had to get my mindset
anthony are you doing what you love are
you doing it excellently and are you is
peace accompanying that and once i
started to move that direction the quote
unquote success followed that um
because my definition of success changed
my you know my
yeah yeah i love it yeah
walk me through how people can find
peace is it is it prayer is it
conversations is it time alone is it
lots of
time in the shower thinking
yeah
yeah how do you get to that point of
peace because i think if you said how
many people in america right now have
peace it's not going to be that many so
how do we get to peace
i i think it it varies because
everybody's so different but i can speak
obviously what what it meant to me it
means
man there's so many different variables
for me i actually a huge part of my
thing was getting my mind and emotions
set because i'm an emotional dude we're
artists so an emotion can throw you off
track for for three weeks if you don't
let it so i had to
i obviously made sure that my
relationship with god is is good and i'm
i'm connected and and very intentional
about that in addition to that
a big part of that for me was um therapy
like i got into therapy and you know
it's not i'm like big strong dude i
don't need therapy that's kind of my
mind at first but then i was like yeah
you do
you know what i mean so
for me
that was like having a trainer at the
gym
when weights are getting stacked on the
rack like having somebody tell you this
is the way that i can't take the weight
away but i can tell you the proper form
when lifting it i can tell you um how
many reps you need i can i can help you
get it all mapped out in front of you so
that you um
so that you you will
get the most results out of this out of
this heavy lifting so that's what it was
for me my relationship with god and for
those people who are um watching just
knowing that there is something greater
than you at play there's something
greater than what's happening in your
life
in at this moment at play and
understanding which i do
is that
the bigger picture and god's promise to
me and all of us is that he's gonna use
all those things together for our good
so i'm a faith guy sorry i gotta i gotta
i'm not sorry no i'm not gonna bring
that in for everybody don't apologize
it's great i mean you've talked a lot
about belief which i love yes i think
the biggest problem in the world is that
people don't have enough belief so when
you are
talking about you know you're meant for
something more you know you're meant to
serve and the help and to share your
gifts
how do you maintain the belief
when the voice in your head is telling
you but but you're not getting results
yes but nobody wants you on their
station anthony like how do you keep
that belief
strong
when that internal voice is so negative
sometimes the way i've kept it strong is
by bouncing everything that comes into
my head and my heart off of the truth
and the truth to me is understanding
that
everything that happens in my life will
work together for good
so when i have the feelings or or
knowing that like god's gonna finish
what he started in me like that's a huge
thing because there are moments where i
i mean i'm the biggest like
oh
you know i feel left i feel lost i feel
abandoned it's hard today's heart i'm
that guy all day long it's it's it's
kind of weird but i'm just that
emotional it's understanding basically
the bottom line is that emotions do not
have intellect that's what it is it's
understanding the concept that emotions
cannot think so as real as they feel
they have to be bounced off the truth or
they will have you all over the place
emotions cannot be the engine they have
to be the caboose
period i love it so the book is called
divine disruption youtube we're going to
link it in description below
it's interesting the choice of words
because it it in disruption
forces you to go on a different path yes
and the life that maybe you thought you
were going to live is not the one that
is actually the one you have to go up
and live but and i think people struggle
with it i you mentioned therapy and i
see that you know you lost eight family
members in two years
just crazy in researching your stories
like how is this
for me like
that is an easy voice to go to right
like how does this serve me how is this
god's plan how like how does that make
any sense but it's it's a disruptive
plan so talk me through
why disruption is so important
man
that's a i will talk you through that
but when you mention that the eight
family members and all that stuff it's
that's still hard i'm like
god for real like did we did we need to
go this far you know what i mean i i
didn't obviously didn't want any of that
to happen but life throws us curveballs
that is what
that is what happens and it's kind of
what are we gonna do
with those curveballs so i mentioned um
you know you can't build a foundation
you can't build a foundation during a
storm it has to be before or after and i
really believe that so um i i really
believe that disruptions
are going to happen that's that's the
bottom line and are you retrofitted for
those disruptions i i half the time i
live in
los angeles and the houma men the
foundation has been retrofitted for
earthquakes it has been the earthquakes
were thought about before the house was
built so
um now if there's an earthquake yes i
may have to go put pictures back up on
the wall and and figure that out but
because it was built with earthquakes in
mind it can withstand them
in a way that something that wasn't
built with them in mind can can't
so my my uh my encouragement to
everybody watching is to know that
disruptions are going to come it is
going to be a problem and unfortunately
that is what
it is but we have the option to retrofit
our hearts we have the option to
retrofit our minds we have the option to
retrofit our emotions so that when they
come it doesn't negate the shaking but
it but it
it changes what the shaking does to our
lives
that's what this book is about and it's
a family conversation it is a it's me my
siblings my three siblings sorry
me and my three siblings and my father
and it's like welcoming you to our table
and talking about how even though we all
have crazy different personalities how
we handled the disruptions and how we
retrofitted our hearts and our lives to
um
so that the shaking didn't just didn't
destroy us and and also sorry i'm just
rambling on i had this is great no no
that's great when i have coffee evan
it's like hold on here we go let's go
you know i i for a while i was a big
well still now i watched fixer upper
quite a bit you know i watched chip and
joe a lot of people watch chip and joe
and i noticed before any
before those beautiful renovations
happened there always had to be a
demolition there is always a demolition
before there's a renovation so now when
disruptions happen even though it
doesn't negate how much they hurt it
doesn't negate
uh it doesn't get any of that i look at
them as a renovation is coming
and i don't know what that's going to be
but a renovation is coming and that
stacked on top of my faith and knowing
that the end of the at the end of the
day i'm going to see my mother again i'm
going to see my other seven family
members again that when coupled with
the understanding that a demolition
comes before a renovation
helps me to push through
the disruptions in it in a different way
and what i love about the message in the
book is that
it's not only that disruptions will come
but that they're divine
yeah like they're guiding you somewhere
it's not that you just have to handle
this like it's actually taking you to
somewhere that you need to be which is a
total mind twist on a lot of these
[ __ ] we see them as negative things
which they are but it's like it's
actually making you stronger and it's
guiding to a different spot 100 percent
i believe that certain things happen
on a nut on a level that we can't
understand it
certain things most things almost all
things i think happen on a level that we
cannot cognitively understand
but when you stop looking at the
circumstance and look at what you can do
with who you are in that circumstance
then everything changes because you
understand it's divine you know like
i'll i'll use simone biles for an
example she is 410 a tiny human being
i'm sure it's hard for her to reach
stuff in her house and that's the way
she was made that's the way she was
divinely made for some odd reason she's
4 10 she can't reach up in her house i'm
sure pushing the pedals in her car is
hard at times you know everything is
different because of the way she's built
but if you ask her do you wish you were
taller i bet you she'd hold out
50 60s
hundreds of medals and trophies and go
what do you think
because she has figured out a way to
maximize the way that she was made
that she was divinely made one way and
instead of going instead of trying to
join the basketball team and putting
herself in a position to be constantly
feeling like a failure she has taken the
way she has made and figured out a way
to be a champion with that and i believe
we all have the option of looking at
what's divinely happening in our lives
and deciding
how are we going to become a champion
with these divine circumstances that are
that i've been put in
sometimes without me wanting to she
didn't ask to be 410 she just figured
out a way to become a champion at 4 10.
man
i think if you ask most people they're
going to be saying i wish i was like
this person that person taller like him
and had more followers like her and
could sing like anthony and all of these
things right how do we how do we
get rid of that voice
getting that that voice starts with the
the
making sure that you silence you can
hear the voice of your uniqueness when
you silence the voice of comparison
when you silence the i wish i was more
like and that allows the voice to be to
become louder of but this is how you are
made this is what divinely is going on
in your life at this moment and what can
you do to maximize that this book
although
i actually would prefer to not have a
book and have my mother back obviously
because this book would not this book
wouldn't have happened
um but
because those circumstances are things i
can i cannot control they're totally out
of my control i want my mother here so
bad
when she passed i remember thinking
we have to honor her legacy in a way
that
somehow brings some kind of justice and
legacy out of this moment and that is
why we are sitting down that's why we
sat down and wrote this book
and i i look at the book and although i
want my mom back i'm like this is what
you do when you take a circumstance that
you can't change
and you make the most of it because now
my mother's story in our story will be
able to
touch countless amounts amounts of
people because we looked at the scenario
and said what can we do with this
what can we do with this
i love it you're talking to probably one
of my greatest fears my parents are both
alive right now
they're on the wall behind me like
that's my dad
that's me when i'm like eight years old
and so i i don't know how i'm gonna
handle it um when at some point it
happens but you know the way you guys
have done it just been a huge
inspiration
um
do you have triggers
like how do you catch it when when the
voice you mention you're an emotional
guy it's easy to get lost in those
emotions and they can derail you for
weeks if you let them and i think a lot
of people let themselves get trapped how
do you how do you catch it and pull
yourself out of the spiral they're
triggers are there words is there
feeling like how do you pull yourself
out when it happens oh yeah there's
there's there's a lot of them i have to
understand
man
first of all i had to identify the
triggers in in my life sometimes
walking through my own life was like
walking through a minefield i didn't
know what were the things that set me
off and i think a lot of times we i have
friends that are like that but i'll talk
about me you you there are
buried minds in your soul and in your
emotions and i the way that i have been
able to come to peace with those or dig
those up and and and
and um
sorry uh unset them that's not the right
word i was looking for basically dig
them up and
not make them triggers anymore was i had
to be willing to do the work
digging up a trigger digging up a mind
it takes work
and and um
dude sorry my brain just it's called no
you're doing it your question is it
makes me like
that's great what's the word oh diffuse
diffuse sorry when you defuse a bomb or
diffuse a trigger i have to dig
something up that takes work and that's
how i got to the point and it's still
it's so hard for me because there are
certain things that still feeling
devalued is a trigger of mine because of
what happened earlier in my career and
things that happened in childhood
everybody was doing their best but
feeling devalued is a problem for me so
i defuse it and sometimes it'll
reconnect itself and you have to
constantly diffuse those things but once
you realize that those explosions hurt
you and everybody around you then you
are more likely to want to when you want
to be healthy and you don't want to be
the guy who pops off every two seconds
and you realize that's a distraction to
you everybody in your life that will
encourage you to do the work and for me
doing the work is obviously my
relationship with with the lord but also
therapy like i had to dig down and
figure out how do i defuse this somebody
help me teach me how to defuse this
because it's distracting
i love it well we value you anthony yeah
behind the scenes so you know your your
pr people whenever reached out to me and
they said hey who do you want to have on
to talk about the book is like i want
anthony
it was great it's great to have you i i
love i love that you talk about therapy
as well and mental health and there's
still a big stigma around it and just a
willingness to ask for help and to
seek a professional to help guide you
through some of these things yeah
for for somebody who might be on the
fence who might be struggling or might
be going through their own emotional
demons right now
what would you tell them about therapy
and how it's helped you i think that it
i think that you taking this step in
that direction and sometimes i've had a
few therapists where the first one i was
like this isn't working this isn't right
but i think that
your biggest
accomplishments your biggest delivery
from whatever it is that's going on
inside of you um your biggest joy is
always
tied to you going being willing to go to
the other side of your fear
when you go to the other side of your
fear you get to experience things that
you never would have thought and for a
lot of people therapy is like why would
i go digging down i don't want to stir
that stuff up but it's there like it's
it's there so you might as well get rid
of it as opposed to burying it so i
would encourage you to just just take
step one don't think about
all the tears you may shed just think
about step one which is trying to find
and there's so many opportunities now
like mental health is such a thing
there's so many opportunities now for
you to just take a step and reach out i
mean you could talk you could do it on
talk space for a second just to feel out
how's this gonna work for me but i would
say if you're fearful of it
your your your biggest
joy is on the other side of that fear
what was there something that pushed you
over the edge in terms of like this
there's fear there's hesitancy to go and
and have that first session
and if you think back to who anthony was
before maybe somebody suggested go talk
to the therapist you're like i'm not
going to talk to the therapist yeah yeah
yeah what was the
push over to say you know what okay now
i'm gonna do it
the push was when i was i was literally
in the shower which isn't too much
information but i was in the shower and
tears were coming coming out of my eyes
i didn't even know why and i couldn't
stop them
and i thought
something is trying to get out
like
something inside of you wants out and
you need to figure out
what that is and dig and i had general
ideas but that that was when i was like
i got to think i got to figure this out
because it was starting to bleed
everywhere like everybody knew me as the
the guy everybody close to me knew me as
like what mood is he in today is he
going to pop off that is not like it's
that kind of thing
and being known as that person and also
being heavily emotional all the time and
my work was suffering i would go sing
places and it was like a shell of a
person was singing to people
i remember one time i went to an
audience and i started telling them
everything that was going on in my life
because i was like and they were looking
at me like no just saying this is too
much like we don't want to know all that
and i thought you got to figure this out
man because you're an emotional wreck so
that for me is what that's what started
it is when i realized i wasn't operating
at all at all cylinders
what do you think is the
most important daily habit you have to
to keep you on track to keep you in
peace like you call it
the most important daily habit that i
have is spending and it's hard for me
because i'm move move a lot is starting
my day and trying to start it in
in solitude and in silence and not
snatching my phone spending time
acknowledging the lord acknowledging god
in my life having a moment of prayer and
then
i
just write in a close second to that is
being active
like
i did not know how much that mattered
until later in my life when i'm active
or thoughts are like having those um
having time for my brain to just space
out and to be active
that helps me get
get get centered just making time
for me before i grab the phone or grab
you know the computer or whatever that
that's that's huge
cool
i want to i wonder if you could lead us
and this idea is coming to me this is
the vine
yes yes
give it to me
i wonder if you could lead us
in a blessing in a song in a prayer like
whatever's flowing for other people
who've been watching this live or on the
youtube replay who feel stuck who feel
like they're capable of more who who are
tired of being tired and frustrated and
just want to release and and
and find their true selves and go on
like is there something you can lead us
in just speak to those people how about
i'll do a little bit of both i'll give
you a little bit of a song that i love
singing all the time to remind myself
that no matter what's going on
externally i'm at peace on the inside
and then i'll lead us in a prayer too i
love that let's go man let's go
little bit of both
will peace like a river
time death my way
when sorrows like sea belows road
whatever
my love
thou has taught me
to say
it is well
it is when
with
my
soul
[Music]
it is well
[Music]
with my
soul
[Music]
it is where
[Music]
it is
[Music]
lord for everybody on here that's
watching for everybody who will watch
i pray that you will bring a peace that
surpasses all of our understanding
into our lives and in all the chaos and
the disruptions that we have personally
the disruptions we've had globally
civil i mean all the all the disruptions
that are happening right now i pray that
you would bring a piece and start to
show us a little glimpse
of the hope that lies and trusting in
you working all things together for our
good
for those on here who know you for those
on here who have are new to this i pray
god that now that supernaturally that
you will give them a peace and an
understanding of you working all things
together
for good open our eyes
to what is truly in store for all of us
if we just hang on tight in your name we
pray amen
amen
anthony evans in the house ladies and
gentlemen the book is called divine
disruption go pick it up youtube again
it's in the description below dude i
appreciate you so much that was
beautiful you sent me on for my day
it's just a tremendous joy to be in your
presence yo i loved it evan thank you
for having me man and i i've loved
following you and you you inspire me
constantly so i'm glad i could give a
little bit back
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with bishop td jakes check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there well i think first thing you
have to realize
there comes a point that your brain
becomes more important than your hands
and you have to figure out what point
that is uh good leadership is working
yourself out of a job